[Musik]
ich habe den Vatikan zum ersten Mal am 9
märz 1993 betreten was für ein
Nervenkitzel ein großer Nervenkitzel
denn ich habe zwar immer meine Kunden
besucht auch institutionelle Kunden aber
für einen Katholiken ist das hier etwas
Besonderes etwas sehr aufregendes
[Musik]
alle meine Freunde wussten dass ich seit
vielen Jahren als Manager tätig war und
wenn sie mich sahen nannten sie mich
immer den Bankier Gottes
[Musik]
das war natürlich ein geistreicher
Scherz für den ich heute leider auch
wirklich brutale Weise bezahlen muss tja
da bin ich nun
[Musik]
mea culpa Korruption im Vatikan
er kann ich es abnehmen danke
[Musik]
junge
das ist so real denn gestern bis zwei
Minuten nach sechs hatte ich das Gefühl
einen Freund des Papstes zu sein ein
treuer Gefolgsmann des Papstes und dann
steht der Papst hier und sagt mir dass
er mir nicht mehr vertraut
wahrscheinlich konnte der Papst nicht
ahnen was für Skandale eine Untersuchung
über den Erwerb eines großen Gebäudes im
Zentrum Londons auslösen könnte es
handelt sich um den schwersten
Finanzskandal der letzten 30 Jahre im
vatikamenciao es ist eine Art Vatikan
Gate bei dem franziskus beschlossen hat
zumindest scheinbar niemandem gegenüber
Rechenschaft abzulegen
es ist ein Skandal sie haben Dinge getan
die nicht anständig waren
ich lese jeden Tag das bulleton dass der
Heilige Stuhl auf seiner Website
veröffentlicht Anfang Oktober 2019 stand
dort in drei Zeilen ganz lapidar dass
die vatikanische Gendarmerie eine Reihe
von Durchsuchungen im Büro des
staatssekretariats durchgeführt hat da
es sich um das Büro handelt das dem
Papst am nächsten steht konnten wir
erkennen dass eine erschütternde
Untersuchung begonnen hatte und dass
eine solche Aktion im Vatikan
offensichtlich nicht ohne die Billigung
und Genehmigung von Papst franziskus
beschlossen werden konnte
ist natürlich
es war der interne Prüfer der sagte dass
hier etwas Schlimmes vorlag
er kam zu mir und ich fragte ihn ob er
sich sicher sei er zeigte mir die Zahlen
und fragte mich was er tun sollte
dafür ist die vatikanische
justizzuständig geh und melde es den
Promotor der Justiz
bat mich um die Erlaubnis für die
Durchsuchungen es bestand der Verdacht
der Korruption und in diesen Fällen
sagte er müsse er dieses Büro
durchsuchen dieses Büro also
unterschrieb ich die Genehmigung
[Musik]
was wir Ihnen erzählen werden ist eine
Geschichte die sich im operativen Herzen
des Vatikans abspielen in dem dem Papst
am nächsten stehenden Ministerium dem
Staatssekretariat das bis in die Schweiz
hineinreicht um diese komplizierte
Geschichte verständlicher zu gestalten
haben wir beschlossen einiges Szenen mit
Schauspielern nachzustellen im
Mittelpunkt der Ermittlungen steht eine
Handvoll Finanziers und hochrangiger
Prälaten die von der vatikanischen
justizverdächtigt werden einen
Kriminellen Plan zur Plünderung der
vatikanischen Staatskasse ausgehängt zu
haben
[Musik]
ich habe einen Anruf vom
Staatssekretariat erhalten monsignora
Angelo beccio wollte mit mir sprechen um
mich mit einer bestimmten Aufgabe zu
betreiben
er sagte mir hören Sie ich habe einen
sehr guten Freund der die Rechte an
einem Ölfeld in Angola besitzt damals
war die Rede vom größten jemals in
Afrika entdeckten ölfällt etwa 180.000
Barrel pro Tag etwas riesiges
Förderungen für 25 Jahre
mich um eine Stellungnahme für mich war
das ein absolutes Novum denn ich war
ausschließlich im Finanzbereich tätig
wir haben Enrico kraso in Lugano
getroffen der Treuhänder ist eine
zentrale Figur in dieser Untersuchung
die seit Monaten das Interesse der
großen nationalen Zeitungen auf sich
zieht und wieder einmal wirft sie ein
schlechtes Licht auf dem Tessiner
Finanzplatz Grasso ist seit über 20
Jahren externer formanager des
staatssekretariats im Auftrag mehrerer
Banken zuletzt für die Kredit Suisse im
Jahr 2014 zog er von Rom nach Lugano um
seine eigene Treuhandgesellschaft zur
Channel zu eröffnen der ehemalige Banker
hat sich bereit erklärt uns in einem
ausführlichen Interview seine Sicht der
Dinge zu schildern
das ist eine treuhandurkunde ein paar
golfpokale hier und da ich habe den
roadory Pokal gewonnen
die Geschichte begann im Jahr 2013 als
Monsignore beccio in wegen einer
Investition im Ölsektor kontaktierte
hey du Weber valutare sie mussten den
Wert dieses Geschäfts schätzen aber war
eine Investition in Öl ethisch
vertretbar
das ist eine gute Frage aber wenn eine
Institution einen investitionsvorschlag
hat gehe ich davon aus dass diese Aspekt
von ihrer Seite aus bereits geprüft und
berücksichtigt worden ist
wie viel hat der Vatikan investieren
sollen sie sprachen von 200 Millionen
Dollar
Monsignore Angelo becchio der Schöpfer
dieser Investition bekleidete damals das
Amt des Stellvertreters für Allgemeine
Angelegenheiten das heißt es
Stellvertreters des Leiters des
staatssekretariats Kardinal pardolin er
war der dritte in der Hierarchie des
Vatikans
[Musik]
Staatssekretariat verfügt über eine
Staatskasse von 650 Millionen Euro die
sich zu einem Drittel aus einem Fond dem
sogenannten Paul dem sechsten Fonds und
zu zwei Dritteln aus einem vor des
petrusdienstes speist
so langsam
400 Millionen Euro wert ist stammt
stattdessen aus allen Almosen die dem
Papst von den Gläubigen aus aller Welt
direkt gespendet werden
das Staatssekretariat sollte das Geld
aus dem peterspfennig für die
Unterstützung der ärmsten verwenden auch
für die Verwaltung der Weltkirche
ist quasi so wie eine riesige
almosenbüchse in einer Kirche
er ist im Grunde eine Art Geldautomat
und der ist wichtig
Ihnen zur Verfügung das Sie investieren
können und das nicht von vornherein
einer Kontrolle durch den ior unterliegt
Kardinal bethschuhe hat testamentarisch
verfügt dass ein Teil der Gelder aus dem
Peters Pfennig der aus den Spenden der
Gläubigen an den Papst stammt und zur
Unterstützung der Kirche und der Ärmsten
der Armen bestimmt ist in eine Ölquelle
in Angola investiert werden soll
für die päpstlichen Richter ist dies das
erste Verbrechen das ihnen vorgeworfen
wird die Zweckentfremdung von Geldern
die für wohltätige Zwecke bestimmt waren
für eine spektakuläre Anlage eine
Anschuldigung die auch Enrico Grasso
betraf der dem Staatssekretariat
geholfen haben soll die wahre Herkunft
des Geldes zu verschleiern indem er sich
die zu investierende Summe bei den
Banken geliehen und das Geld aus dem
peterspfennig verpfändet hat
[Musik]
das Geld das für wohltätige Zwecke
verwendet werden sollte das war das Geld
aus dem peterspennig
aber sie haben es den Vermögensverwalter
nicht gesagt Sie haben uns nicht gesagt
dass die Gelder für wohltätige Zwecke
sind ich weiß nicht ob den Banken gesagt
wurde dass sie mit dem Geld dass sie
bekamen vorsichtig umgehen sollten dass
es nur für wohltätige Zwecke verwaltet
werden durfte nein denn sonst hätten die
Banken keine Operation durchgeführt aber
ich würde gerne wissen warum stellen Sie
mir diese Frage
mit dem Auftrag den er erhalten hatte
musste Enrico Grasso das Geschäft auf
Machbarkeit überprüfen weil er aber
keine Erfahrung im Ölsektor hatte suchte
er nach einem Experten
[Musik]
ich sagte ihm eure Exzellenz meine
Erfahrung ist finanzieller Natur ich
kann Ihnen natürlich helfen aber was den
technischen Teil angeht muss ich Ihnen
sagen dass ich mich mit meiner Bank in
Verbindung setzen werde er sagte ja ja
bleiben Sie ganz ruhig verhalten sie
sich sehr diskret wir müssen es nicht
tun wenn es machbar ist wenn es
interessant ist und alle Kriterien
erfüllt sind werden wir es machen
ansonsten nicht
[Musik]
wie es darauf hin dass ich zu der Bank
gehen würde mit der ich arbeite und so
weiter und die Credit Suisse Ried mir
nach London zu gehen wo ich mit der
minzone-gruppe bekannt gemacht wurde die
Experten auf dem Gebiet Gruppe
zu diesem Zeitpunkt tauchte im Vatikan
eine neue mysteriöse Figur auf Rafael
limencione ein internationaler Finanzier
italienischer Abstammung der in London
Mailand und Luxemburg tätig war
[Musik]
sie haben Raffael miccione zum ersten
Mal in London getroffen was war ihr
Eindruck von ihm
[Musik]
ein Experte zu sein er erzählte mir dass
er aus einer zerrütteten Familie stammt
sein Vater hatte einige Schwierigkeiten
zog nach London und gründete von dort
aus seinen Unternehmen
er sagte er habe ein enges Verhältnis
mit der enie-gruppe die Bank habe mit
ihm in London Geschäfte gemacht
er meinte also wenn derjenige der ihn
mir vorgestellt hat ihm vertraut müsse
ich mir keine Sorgen machen
dann hat er ihnen den Kardinal
vorgestellt nämlich an
das habe ich
nachdem Sie die Zustimmung von Kardinal
Angelo becchio erhalten hatten machten
sich Rafael le missione und Enrico
Grasso an die Arbeit um die technische
und finanzielle Machbarkeit der
Investition zu prüfen in der
Zwischenzeit wurden die 200 Millionen
die für die Investition vorgesehen waren
umgehend auf einen Fond im Besitz von
Rafael le missione übertragen doch nach
einem Jahr der Studien und Bewertungen
gaben die beiden Finanziers ein
negatives Urteil und treten von dem
Geschäft ab
bereitete die Arme aus wie es üblich ist
und rührte keinen Finger als wollte er
sagen mal sehen machen wir es und damit
war alles zu Ende denn die Operation
wurde nicht fortgeführt
[Musik]
im Staatssekretariat herrscht heute
große Unruhe es ist der 7 juni 2013 und
soeben ist ein Bericht aus Lugano
eingetroffen der einen dunklen Schatten
auf die Figur von Raffaello missione
wirft
sie es handelt sich um einen Artikel aus
der Wochenzeitung il mondo den die
Credit Suisse an den Schatzmeister des
Sekretariats Fabrizio Tina Bassi und an
Monsignore perlasca die rechte Hand von
Erzbischof Angelo becchio geschickt hat
in dem Artikel steht dass einige
italienische Abgeordnete nach dem
Versuch des finanziells die Banker
populare di Milano zu übernehmen
parlamentarische Anfragen gestellt haben
um sich über die Undurchsichtigkeit der
Finanzströme seines Unternehmens und
über die Schwierigkeit die Herkunft
seiner finanziellen Mittel
zurechtfertigen zu beschweren
[Musik]
hallo ja Herr tierabasi
und ein Bericht der ernst genommen
werden muss ist es möglich dass niemand
im Sekretariat diesen Verdachtsfällen
nachgegangen ist ich wollte wissen wie
sie zum Fall des Vatikans stehen
t haben aber
kein Kommentar auch von Monsignore
perlaska die Gerichtsdokumente zeigen
jedoch dass sich die Beziehung zwischen
dem Staatssekretariat und
raphaelemencione trotz dieser dunklen
Schatten sogar noch verstärkt hat fürs
Auto
hat der Kontakt zwischen Raphael
emissione und dem Staatssekretariat
gehalten
ja es wurde ein Kontakt hergestellt und
damit die Möglichkeit des Vertrauen des
Kunden zu gewinnen
und das hat er geschafft
er schlug eine weitere Investition vor
und sie stimmten zu
wir schreiben den juli 2014 ein
zentraler Moment in dieser Geschichte
als das Staatssekretariat beschließt die
Idee in die Ölquelle in Angola zu
investieren endgültig aufzugeben und
sein Interesse auf ein anderes
Unternehmen zu
richtene schlug vor ein Gebäude in
London zu kaufen das alte Kaufhaus
Harrods das einer seiner Firmen gehörte
das Projekt wurde sofort von Fabrizio
tedabasi und Monsignore perlaska
befürwortet
[Musik]
Gebäudes wurde als eine sehr günstige
Investition dargestellt
unter seinem Marktwert lag
30 bis 40 Prozent unter dem was sie mit
dem Verkauf oder sogar mit der
Renovierung hätten erzielen können weil
es eine Art Baugenehmigung gab die die
Erhöhung und den Bau erlaubte es würde
eine große Immobilieninvestition werden
es ist ein wunderschönes Gebäude das
alte Kaufhaus Harrods in London ein
Trophy asset wie man es nennt und
so einigen sich die Parteien darauf wie
die 200 Millionen Dollar investiert
werden sollen die das Staatssekretariat
bereits oder Faile missione anvertraut
hatte und die in seinen Athena
Investmentfonds geflossen waren
100 Millionen Dollar wurden für den Kauf
von 45% der Anteile an dem Londoner
Gebäude bereitgestellt das dem
mincionefon gehört hatte der Rest wurde
in Finanzinstrumente desselben Athena
Fonds investiert
sie waren nicht Eigentümer des Gebäudes
sondern Besitzer von Fondant teilen die
Vereinbarungen sahen vor dass die
anderen liquiden Mittel in vereinbarten
Finanzinstrumenten angelegt werden
sollten
aber
ein bisschen hatte als
Vermögensverwalter gehandelt und sie so
eingesetzt wie er es eben tat
der Vatikan war also nicht der direkte
Eigentümer des Gebäudes sondern nur
Besitzer von Fondsanteilen den Richtern
zufolge sorgte miccione auch für einen
großen Verlust für den Heiligen Stuhl
indem er die verbleibenden 100 Millionen
in Finanzinstrumente von Unternehmen die
mit ihm verbunden sind oder auf jeden
Fall in spekulative und illiquide
Finanzinstrumente investierter
[Musik]
man darf nicht vergessen dass es an den
Finanzmärkten nach 2008 immer weiter
nach oben ging guilaparte
finanzanteil also ich will nicht sagen
umsichtig aber gewissenhaft verwaltet
worden wäre während die Erträge
höchstwahrscheinlich höher gewesen als
die Verwaltungsgebühren
schrieb der Athena Fond tiefroute zahlen
und verbrannte in fünf Jahren 18
Millionen Euro wie die Berechnungen der
päpstlichen Justiz zeigen aber nicht nur
das für die Durchführung dieser
Operationen die zu dem wirtschaftlichen
Desaster führten hätte der Fond von
Rafael le missione dem Staatssekretariat
weitere 18 Millionen Euro an Provisionen
in Rechnung gestellt
guten Morgen Ich suche Mister minchione
er ist nicht hier um wie viel Uhr kommt
er wieder er kommt nicht er ist nicht
hier aber wohnt er hier
befinden uns also wieder einmal im
Herzen der Schweiz in Celerina nur einen
Steinwurf von St Moritz entfernt hier
ist der Finanzier offiziell gemeldet
aber wir treffen nur einen seiner
Bediensteten an keine Spur von ihm
[Musik]
nein nein er war in den letzten Monaten
wegen des Coronavirus da aber
normalerweise wohnt er nicht hier
[Musik]
ist bekannt dass er in Celerina wohnhaft
war
i fatico steht es in den Unterlagen der
Staatsanwaltschaft der finanziell hat
außerdem große Interessen in der Schweiz
nicht nur weil einige seiner Unternehmen
dort ansässig sind sondern auch weil er
Miteigentümer des legendären Hotel Palas
in St Moritz ist wir hatten also gerne
seine Seite der Geschichte erfahren
zumal die Ermittler missione selbst als
die Person bezeichnen die am meisten von
dem Londoner Missgeschick des Heiligen
Stuhls profitiert hätte
am Telefon erreichen wir seine
Haushälterin
[Musik]
erklären Sie ihm dass es besser wäre
wenn er mir ein Interview gibt
wenn er sich dafür zur Verfügung stellt
kann er mir sagen wie seine Position ist
weil sich herausgestellt hat dass er
viele Millionen abgezweigt hat
diese Summen entziehen sich
Normalsterblichen das ist die
Schwierigkeit die ich oft habe wenn ich
sie nenne und den Leser davon erzähle
dieses Geld genommen hat können wir
ableiten wie sehr nicht nur der Wille
der Spender sondern auch der Wille des
Papstes verraten wurde wir können also
davon ausgehen dass es das Ziel des
Papstes ist das Geld wieder zu erlangen
und vor allem die Schuldigen innerhalb
des Heiligen Stuhls zu bestrafen
es war im Mai 2018 als etwas bizarres
geschah der Papst erhob Erzbischof
Angelo bechcure in den Rang eines
Kardinals und ernannte ihn zum perfekten
der Kongregation für die selig und
Heiligsprechungen es mag wie eine
Beförderung erscheinen aber in
Wirklichkeit das sagen viele Leute im
Vatikan bei der einzige Zweck dieser
Geste an jillo bettgio von der Leitung
des staatssekretariats zu entfernen
im Vatikan herrschte bereits eine
wachsende Verlegenheit über die
Situation die durch diese verlustreiche
Investition entstanden war und man war
sich nicht einig darüber was zu tun
Seifer
[Musik]
hallo
sind sie Stadtrad vignone
der Anwalt von Kardinal beccio
nun ich rufe sie an weil ich sie um eine
Stellungnahme oder ein Interview bitten
wollte
wir hätten gerne von der betroffenen
Person gewusst warum sie ausgerechnet
das Geld das dem Papst von den Gläubigen
angeboten wurde in ein so obskurris und
spekulatives Geschäft investieren wollte
doch seine Eminenz lehnte jeden
Kommentar ab
will er nichts dazu sagen
seine Sache die Sie tun sollten und das
habe ich schon im Februar 2017 gesagt
ist die Rückerstattung zu bekommen eine
Lösung zu finden aber vor allem eine
Bewertung der Immobilie vorzunehmen
mit wem haben Sie gesprochen ich habe
einen Monsignore per Laska und Herren
therabassi geschrieben und was haben sie
geantwortet sie haben nicht geantwortet
tatsächlich beschlossen die Leiter des
Sekretariats erst im November 2018 nach
dem Abgang von Kardinal beccio den Fonds
von Rafael lemiccione zu verlassen
allerdings mit dem Ziel das gesamte
Gebäude in London zu kaufen an dem sie
bereits 45% der Anteile besaßen sie
konnten sich jedoch nicht mit dem
finanziell einigen finanzielle und in
diesem Moment betritt ein neuer Akteur
ebenfalls aus London die Bühne unseres
Rollenspiels ein weiterer Makler mit
italienischen Wurzeln
wurde gebeten ein Problem zu lösen dass
das Staatssekretariat zu dieser Zeit
hatte es war ein ziemlich dringendes
Problem
es ging darum einen Weg zu finden der es
dem Staatssekretariat ermöglichte das
Eigentum an der Immobilie
wiederzuerlangen
identifizierte sich damit aus vielerle
abgesehen von seinen eigenen beruflichen
Fähigkeiten kannte er vor allem Herrn
missione gut
sie wurde als Lösung präsentiert um aus
dem Deal mit mentione herauszukommen
er sagte terabasi dass er derjenige sei
der Mensch ohne davon überzeugen könne
das Gebäude aufzugeben
nun er sagte das Mensch ohne den er sehr
gut kannte wegen der
Geschäftsbeziehungen die sie hatten und
die er manchmal mit seinen Firmen
finanzierte nicht nein sagen konnte ich
war jedoch ein wenig skeptisch was die
Tatsache betraf das torz in den schone
finanziert hat
in Wirklichkeit aber traf torzi in
Wirklichkeit der torz schone davon
überzeugt das Gebäude zu verkaufen
um einen Termin im Sekretariat und
unterbreitete perlaska und terabasi
einen Vorschlag
davon überzeugt und dass zu diesem Preis
er wäre bereit das Gebäude zu verkaufen
Millionen Pfund
das ist die Summe auf die sich die
beiden italienisch-englischen Geldgeber
geeinigt haben und die torze dem Vatikan
überreicht eine beachtliche Zahl die
nach Ansicht der päpstlichen Justiz
jeder rechtlichen und wirtschaftlichen
Grundlage zu entbehren scheint
super vor allem wenn man bedenkt dass
das Sekretariat bereits 200 Millionen
Dollar in den Fonds von Rafael le
missione eingezahlt hatte und dass die
Immobilie mit einem Teil der Kosten
belastet war tatsächlich gab der Vatikan
363 Millionen Euro für ein Gebäude aus
das Raffaello mencione sechs Jahre zuvor
für weniger als die Hälfte dieser Summe
erworben hatte
Millionen wie kamen diese 40 Millionen
für Mister missione zusammen
offensichtlich sind die 40 Millionen
nicht auf Initiative von Herrn torzi
zustande gekommen in dem Sinne das
natürlich auch das Staatssekretariat ein
klares Interesse an der
Schadensminimierung gezeigt hat das
liegt auf der Hand offensichtlich hat
Herr missione auf ein für ihn sicherlich
sehr wichtiges Geschäft verzichtet
angesichts einer Liquidation die groß
genug sein musste um das
Staatssekretariat zurück in den Besitz
der Immobilie bringen zu können
waren sie etwas überrascht
sehen Sie wir waren ein wenig überrascht
aber wissen Sie wenn der Kunde zufrieden
ist
ich war erstaunt darüber wie leicht es
war für etwas eine Lösung in sechs bis
sieben Tagen zu finden und dass ich seit
dem 17 januar 2017 gebangt hatte
aber wer ist die Person die den Vatikan
innerhalb weniger Tage aus der
Bredouille zu bringen
[Musik]
darüber haben wir neulich erst
gesprochen weil ich es selbst wissen
wollte
sie war glücklich darüber er sagte nein
ich hatte einfach Glück weil ich es
geschafft habe in Kreise zu gelangen an
die ich nicht mal zu träumen gewagt
hätte
[Musik]
Schulter
einer kleinen Stadt in mollisse auf und
besuchte die Schule für Landwirtschaft
[Applaus]
sein Vater Enrico hatte ein
Getreidelager und stellte Düngemittel
her
Familienunternehmen
Hochzeiten zu tanzen gründete er zur
gleichen Zeit ein weiteres Unternehmen
im Bereich Wasseraufbereitung oder
bilizationen
was ist aus diesen beiden Unternehmen
geworden
nichts beide sind bankrott gegangen
hat um seine Ziele zu erreichen leider
das Leben seiner Familie verkompliziert
und Schulden gemacht die dann zum
Bankrott führten wahrscheinlich
von Düngemitteln zum Tempel des Herrn
durch verschiedene familiäre Misserfolge
hindurch so begann John Luigi tortis
Karriere und führte ihn nach London
mitten ins Herz der Stadt
er ist nicht der klassische Italiener
aus einer Kleinstadt der nach London
geht und dort zunächst einmal als
Tellerwäscher anfängt nein er ging mit
einem Unternehmen dorthin das bereit war
auf dem Markt mitzumischen
[Musik]
Sprung von einer kleinen Stadt in
mollisse und von der Produktion von
Düngemitteln hin zur Verwaltung
internationaler Fonds schafft man nicht
einfach nur weil man gut daran ist
wie ist der dort hingekommen guillionesi
ist das Nervenzentrum der
römisch-katholischen Bewegung
Gemeinschaft und Befreiung in molisse
[Musik]
es gibt dort eine sehr starke
Gemeinschaft höchstwahrscheinlich
ergaben sich die Verbindungen zum
Vatikan direkt aus der Bewegung auch
weil einer der Beteiligten der Bewegung
sehr sehr nahe stand
[Musik]
der Unternehmer aus molice kommt also an
die Schwelle des Heiligen Stuhls um den
Streit um das Londoner Gebäude zu
schlichten doch zu diesem Zeitpunkt war
die saumstrittene Manager bereits durch
einen rechtlichen Zwischenfall mit
verstörenden Grundzügen in mulisse
vorbelastet
[Musik]
wir sprechen von gianluigi torzi der uns
geschadet hat sagen wir mal betrogen um
das richtige Wort zu benutzen
denn zunächst trat er an uns heran als
Freunde helfen wollte der etwas tun
wollte kurz gesagt er entpuppte sich als
Judas er hat uns eigentlich um alles
betrogensumme wir befinden uns im
Termoli mulice im Jahr 2010 hat die
Wirtschaftskrise die Familie varanessa
an den Rand der wirtschaftlichen
Katastrophe getrieben die Geschäfte der
Kinder gehen in Konkurs und als sie in
die Enge getrieben werden beschließen
sie mit gianluigitorzi einen Deal
einzugehen und ein Touristendorf zu
bauen sie würden die Familienvilla am
Meer und das Land mitbringen der
Finanzier das Kapital
die Villa hatte einen Handelswert von
einer Millionen und zwei einer Millionen
300.000 Euro
ein Spiel er sagte er würde einen
fiktiven Kaufvertrag aufsetzen indem wir
den Verkaufspreis der Immobilie auf
320.000 Euro setzen so würden wir auch
weniger Steuern zahlen danach würden wir
anfangen zu bauen und alles so machen
und das wurde uns im Grunde zum
Verhängnis
die Firma in der dieses familienjuwel
gelandet ist ist Eigentum von torzi und
nicht von Marcello cornaccione das Dorf
hat keine Baugenehmigung erhalten und
wurde nie gebaut so verlor die Familie
varanessa ihre schöne Villa am Meer de
la bella
Ente von einem Tag auf den anderen sahen
wir uns praktisch von unserem Grundstück
verdrängt raus mit nichts einfach so wie
erstatteten Anzeige bei der
Finanzaufsicht ich habe ihnen gezeigt
dass ich auf Schwindel hereingefallen
bin auf einen Betrug der Beamte drehte
sich um sah mich an und sagte Herr
konaklione sehen Sie diesen Stapel und
er zeigte mir einen Stapel von
Aktenordnern 60 70 cm hoch auf einem
Schreibtisch das sagte der Beamte und
sei mir dabei sehr ernst denn die Augen
ist alles von gianluigi torzi
[Musik]
seitdem fordert die Familie
Gerechtigkeit und sie ist nicht allein
in der Tat gibt es viele offene
Verfahren gegen den Unternehmer einige
sogar vor seinem Eintritt in den Vatikan
gegenwärtig klagt die Justiz ihn wegen
einer Vielzahl von Straftaten in Rom
Mailand Bari und larino an wo im
Dezember 2020 eine erste Anhörung zu
einer Angelegenheit stattfand die mit
der Villa der Familie varanese verbunden
war
nur dala
ricettacione seine Verbrechen reichen
vom Besitz gestohlener Güter bis zum
Hausfriedensbruch
und dazu kommt noch die Anstiftung zu
Verbrechen
was haben sie dann irgendwann
beschlossen zu tun
ich bin plötzlich darauf gekommen dem
Papst zu schreiben und ihm kurz unsere
Situation zu schildern
was Sie geschrieben haben soll ich es
vorlesen
[Musik]
kam genau zur richtigen Zeit und wir
fanden uns in einer Situation wieder in
der uns alles genommen wurde ohne dass
wir es merkten denn alles wurde von
einer liebevollen Fürsorge verschleiert
eine brüderliche Hand bot uns an uns aus
einer schwerwiegenden wirtschaftlichen
Lage zu befreien
[Musik]
mit der Zeit wurde uns klar dass es eine
gelinde gesagt fragwürdige Art war uns
das Grundstück in Termoli zu entreißen
[Musik]
es ist der zweite Weihnachtsfeiertag
2018 als etwas Außergewöhnliches
passiert der Papst gewährt gianluigi
torzi eine
privataudienza wir wissen nicht worüber
sie gesprochen haben aber sicher ist
dieses Treffen ist zentral für das
Verständnis der weiteren Entwicklungen
offenbar hat jemand der den Papst sehr
nahe steht ihm den Finanzier als Retter
des Londoner Gebäudes vorgestellt
[Musik]
zu diesem Zeitpunkt war er Katholik
sowie Herr torzi auch der den Heiligen
Vater besucht hat der für Katholiken ja
das höchste religiöse Oberhaupt der Welt
ist
ich kann Ihnen sagen dass er sichtlich
bewegt war als er von der Begegnung mit
dem Heiligen Vater erzählte
er sagte mir weißt du dass ich heute
Nachmittag in den Vatikan zum Heiligen
Vater gehen muss ich sagte Glückwunsch
gut aber weißt du ich weiß nicht ob ich
gehen soll was soll das heißen Du weißt
nicht ob du gehen sollst ich meine das
ist doch so eine schöne Sache was sagst
du redest du mir zu gehen es war
wirklich absurd
kann man also sagen dass Herr torzi
innerhalb des Vatikans unantastbar
geworden war
nein sagen wir eher er hat ein Problem
gelöst aber ein anderes geschaffen
tatsächlich ging das Gebäude nicht
direkt von Raphael le missionis Athena
an den Vatikan sondern landete bei einer
Firma namens good die gianluigi torti
gehört zu
lagouta die Vereinbarung sah vor dass
das Staatssekretariat in der
Zwischenzeit eine spezielle Gesellschaft
für das Londoner Gebäude und dann für
den Makler aus molicegründen würde die
Aktien verkaufen würde das geschah aber
nicht
als sie diesen Vertrag erhielten
stellten sie fest dass tausend Aktien
der Stimmrechtsanteil bei totzi
verbleiben ich wusste das nicht einmal
das heißt die Aktien mit Stimmrecht
genau und der Vatikan konnte also nichts
mit diesem Gebäude anfangen
sagen wir er war der Eigentümer aber
verwaltet hat es wer stimmberechtigt war
wenn Sie mich fragen wenn er es am
nächsten Tag für 10.000 oder 10
Millionen von täte verkaufen können
hätte er das getan aber war dem Vatikan
ihrer Meinung nach klar dass er ein
Gebäude kauft an dem er keine Rechte
hatte
nein nein ich schließe das völlig aus
[Musik]
diesem Treffen sagte torzi ich werde
dafür sorgen dass sie das Gebäude
zurückerhalten Monsignore perlaska ließ
ihn reden und nach einer Weile sagte er
hören Sie was bringen diese 1000 Aktien
haben wir kein Stimmrecht als sie ihn
lasen erkannten sie es ich habe diesen
Vertrag auch nie gesehen
ja wir sind auf dem Weg
wir nehmen die nächste Ausfahrt
im Heiligen Stuhl gibt es jedoch Stimmen
die behaupten dass die Bedingungen des
Vertrages wohlbekannt waren dies wird
von einem hohen Amtsträger des
Kirchenstaates bestätigt der einem
Treffen zustimmt allerdings unter der
Bedingung anonym zu bleiben
ja das ist er stell es hier links von
ihm ab parke hier okay
ich konnte gerne
der Vertrag den sie mit torxy
unterschrieben haben ergibt keinen Sinn
er macht keinen Sinn ich habe ihn
gesehen
es stand schwarz auf weiß geschrieben
dass die Aktien alle Aktien mit
Stimmrecht an Torte gehen würden während
der Heilige Stuhl diejenigen ohne
Stimmrecht bekam
Erika es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten
entweder war jemand zu naiv oder sie
waren böswillig und haben viel Geld
dafür genommen
wenn man einen Vertrag nicht verstehen
kann geht man zu einem Anwalt richtig
siehst du die Worte
aber nein nein sie haben einfach
unterschrieben
es ist November 2018 als der neue
Stellvertreter für Allgemeine
Angelegenheiten Monsignore Edgar penja
para der Angelo bettgio abgelöst hat die
Operation gut heizt die sich in wenigen
Tagen als kolossaler Fehler erweisen
wird
[Musik]
er hat also in der Tat die volle
Kontrolle über dieses Gebäude obwohl er
keinen Cent hineingesteckt hat als der
Vatikan nach ein paar Wochen beschließt
auch dort sie zu liquidieren sagt hört
sie aber ich habe diese Anteile jetzt
müssen sie mir meine Provision bezahlen
sonst gebe ich diese Anteile nicht
zurück diese Aktien ermöglichten es
torti in der Tat das Gebäude unter
seiner Gewalt zu haben und damit 200
Millionen des Vatikans in seinen Händen
zu halten
wir kommen also zum Epilog zum
verabscheuungswürdigsten Verbrechen das
von den Richtern angenommen wurde die
Erpressung des Vatikans
verlangte vom Heiligen Stuhl zunächst
sogar 20 Millionen Euro um nach mühsamen
Verhandlungen auf 15 Millionen Euro
runterzugehen
lucredo geküste contentosia ich glaube
nicht dass diese Zahlung das Ergebnis
einer Erpressung ist aber es ist eine
Zahlung die offensichtlich mit einem
Vorgang verbunden sein muss
die Wahl Bestand einerseits darin dem
Sekretariat zu ermöglichen das Eigentum
an der Immobilie wieder zu erlangen und
andererseits ist der Firma von Herrn
torzi durch 1000 stimmberechtigte Aktien
zu ermöglichen diese Immobilie fünf
Jahre zu verwalten kann torzi hat man
gesagt er solle sich aus diesem Geschäft
zurückziehen und deshalb sind 15
Millionen vielleicht eine angemessene
Entschädigung für das was man getan und
Herrn totzi offensichtlich in Bezug auf
die Verwaltung einer Immobilie genommen
hat also
mir anvertraut dass er ein Problem hatte
weil Thorsten sich aufgrund dieses
Vertrages berechtigt fühlte 20 Millionen
zu verlangen um die Aktien mit
Stimmrecht zu verkaufen und das
Unternehmen zu verlassen penja para kam
zu mir um er das mitzuteilen sagt die
mit einigem Nachdruck bezahlen Sie ihn
nicht bezahlen Sie ihn nicht
aber das Staatssekretariat gibt nach es
beginnt eine fieberhafte Suche nach Geld
bis Monsignore perlaska Monsignore penia
para eine Lösung vorschlägt das Geld für
die Bezahlung von torzi soll vom
diskretionskonto des Papstes genommen
werden ein Konto das nur dem Heiligen
Vater zur Verfügung steht das entgegen
jeder Logik nicht beim EUR der
Vatikanbank sondern bei einer Schweizer
Bank liegt
[Musik]
genau hier im Zentrum von Lugano
befindet sich das Büro eines Tessiner
Treuhänders der das 2015 bei der UBS
eingerichtete Treuhandkonto des Papstes
verwaltet und von diesem Konto hätte der
Tessiner Treuhänder laut Monsignore
perlaska 20 Millionen Pfund abheben
müssen um die Forderungen von gianluigi
torzi zu erfüllen
die Anweisungen die nach Lugano
geschickt wurden waren sehr präzise 12
Millionen Pfund sollten abgehoben werden
und es sollte ein Überziehungskredit von
weiteren 8 Millionen Pfund beantragt
werden
natürlich hätten wir den Tessiner
Treuhänder gerne getroffen aber aus
Gründen der Diskretion verweigerte er
ein Interview
Pia wir wissen also nicht ob das Konto
des Papstes betroffen ist sicher ist
dass nach Angaben der Justiz in jenen
Tagen 20 Millionen Euro auf einem Konto
der Vatikan Anwälte in London
eingegangen sind und mit diesem Geld
wird gianluigi torzi bezahlt mit zwei
Überweisungen in Höhe von insgesamt 15
Millionen Euro
doch damit ist die Geschichte noch nicht
zu Ende Justiz vermutet dass dort sie
nicht allein gehandelt hat
ich habe dir mein vollstes Vertrauen
geschenkt weil du mit den Arsch gerettet
hast aber Fabi ich will bezahlt werden
ich gehe nicht einfach so gib mir 10
Millionen und ich gehe was zum Teufel
soll ich dir sagen
[Musik]
es ist der 19 dezember 2018 die Lage hat
sich verschlechtert und in einem Hotel
in Mailand findet eine Art gipfeltreppen
statt um tortet sie davon zu überzeugen
die tausend Aktien zu verkaufen aber die
Männer des Vatikans trauen niemandem
mehr und jemand zeichnet das Gespräch
auf
selbst wenn sie mir 10 Millionen geben
ich habe ihm eine Million gezahlt was
denken Sie er hat mich am Abend vorher
angerufen ich habe Überweisung hier ich
erzähle keinen Scheiß verstehen sie er
rief mich am Abend vorher an und sagte
das ist mein Konto bei der UBS
was ist wirklich passiert er sagt
wörtlich gebt mir 8 Millionen gibt mir
10 Millionen von denen ich drei übrig
habe weil ich die anderen mit
schmirgeldern bezahlt habe
sie nicht dass das vielleicht nur
Angeberei war
das Gefechts wäre das eine einfache
Möglichkeit ein einfacher Weg die
Situation aufzulösen klar ist es gibt
dafür keine Beweise
investiger
des Vatikans versuchen herauszufinden ob
dieses Geld komplett an Tod sie ging
oder ob ein Teil dieses Geldes
tatsächlich an Beamte und Monsignore
innerhalb des Vatikans ging
deshalb versuchen Sie herauszufinden ob
es intern Korruption gibt die irgendwie
erklärt warum Knebelverträge
abgeschlossen wurden zum Nachteil des
Vatikans und zum Vorteil der weltlichen
Geldgeber
es ist der 25 September 2020 als Angelo
beccio der vom Skandal um das Londoner
Gebäude und einer Reihe anderer
juristischer Vorfälle überwältigt wurde
vom Heiligen Vater vorgeladen wird
hat mir gesagt dass er mir nicht mehr
traut weil er einen Bericht von den
Richtern bekommen habe dass ich Gelder
veruntreut haben soll ich habe dem
Heiligen Vater gesagt wenn er mir nicht
mehr vertraut gebe ich mein Mandat auf
dann drehte ich zurück das war's hier
mit dem Wetter
seit gestern verzichtet der Kardinal auf
die mit dem Amt verbundenen Rechte und
wird nicht an der Pontifex Wahl
teilnehmen können ich fühle mich nicht
korrumpiert sagte er
die in dieser Untersuchung vermuteten
Verbrechen sind Korruption Veruntreuung
Geldwäsche sogar Erpressung und die
Bildung einer kriminellen Vereinigung
gianluigi torz wurde sogar verhaftet und
kam ins vatikanische Gefängnis zehn Tage
lang mit Hilfe eines
Rechtshilfeersuchens an die Schweizer
Behörden forderte die Staatsanwaltschaft
des Heiligen Stuhls die Herausgabe der
Bankverbindungen und Salden der Konten
von Kardinal beccio Monsignore perlaska
Fabrizio tiabasi Enrico krasso raphaele
mentione
gianluigitorzi und vielen anderen in
Ermangelung eines Urteils gilt derzeit
für alle die Unschuldsvermutung
es wird gegen sie ermittelt sie werden
beschuldigt mit Hort sie kooperiert zu
haben aber ich denke wegen der
Verschwörung
wegen Erpressung Erpressung und das ist
es was mich am meisten betrübt in dem
Rechtshilfe ersuchen werden Sie als die
Person genannt die am meisten von diesem
Londoner Bauvorhaben profitieren sollte
ja so verstehe ich es auch mit torti und
mincione nein nein nein nicht im
geringsten
für Enrico Grasso kommt der Ärger nicht
nur aus dem Vatikan auch in der Schweiz
setzt ihn die justizunter Druck wegen
der Geschäfte mit seinem Centurion
Investmentfonds in denen das
Staatssekretariat rund 50 Millionen Euro
investiert hat eine weitere Geschichte
die sich zu einer Kriminalgeschichte im
Vatikan entwickelt hat der die dunkle
Zeiten für den Bankier Gottes der nur
noch auf Gerechtigkeit warten kann
es stimmt dass ich besorgt bin aber ich
habe keine Angst ich habe Mitleid mit
meinen Kindern mit meinen Enkelkindern
das ist etwas was ich nicht erwartet
habe ich hatte gehofft dass sie sich auf
andere Weise an ihren Großvater erinnern
würden nicht wegen dieses wirklich
unglaublichen Unsinns wissen Sie wie
sich das anfühlt es ist als würde man
mit einem Menschen zusammenarbeiten ihm
helfen und dann dreht man sich
irgendwann um und wird hinterrücks
erstochen so fühlt sich das an
[Musik]